you crazy mother
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
season 9 has come to an end it's been
emotional we've seen things we never
thought possible but how many Easter
eggs did you spot over the season
I found 30 Easter eggs and a few means
to go with that to remember at 1 million
subscribers I will reveal my ugly face
to you so if you're new around here
think about press and subscribe anyway
that's enough begging let's do this
season 9 began on May 9th and ran until
August the 1st 2019 making it the
longest season in fortnight history the
theme was the future with major parts of
the map redesigned to look neon and all
shiny new we even saw frigate spinners
in the sky but what about those Easter
eggs let's start this season
with the online store recognize this
emote this is the new work it emote
which so happens to be taken from a meme
involving a security guard having an
impromptu dance with a team mascot yeah
that's a real thing dammit he's got
moves you gotta admit it
another internet phenomenon known as the
crab rave somehow made it into fortnight
how the heck do we explain this one
simple we don't we just enjoy the
stupidity the most toxic emote in
fortnight dropped this season the deep
dab it looks like the first person to
immortalize this on YouTube was Jack's
films and when you line them both up
yeah the similarities are uncanny
remember the howard the alien mean well
for a while there it took over the
Internet and just as the area 51 memes
returned fortnight introduced Howard the
alien into fortnight known as the
extra-terrestrial emote
[Music]
another mean which refuses to die is the
Fock knife first a mobile kitchen
arrived in fortnight inspired by the
Twitter meme of a girl trying to impress
her boyfriend by playing fortnight and
getting his name wrong this then became
a quarry in season 8 forever
immortalized and finally in season 9
we literally have harvesting tools which
are a fork and knife I gotta admit I
still tweet out my videos with a
fortnight emoji so I'm part of this
problem okay over to the battle puss
let's look at the first character this
is rocks immediately she was claimed by
twitch streamer loser fruit due to the
logo matching hers and a loose
resemblance to her appearance but that's
only one part of the character design
the aesthetics are taken from two other
areas one of those is a children's TV
program named RB Hatcher who keeps fuzzy
pets I half expected that thing to show
up as a new backlink maybe next season
the final character reference becomes
obvious when rocks levels up see the
resemblance
this has to be tracer inspired from
overwatch right elapsed the second
character unlocked right away is
Sentinel who most of us called Robot
Chicken immediately if you know Adult
Swim you'll see why in that Robot
Chicken series there are two versions of
that mother clucker a white one and a
black one and yeah the black version is
in the battle past two but that link is
too tenuous so let's break it down
the Sentinels design closely follows
Gundam designs and in particular the
tall geese by the way both of these
Mexicans live in space foreshadowing for
season 10 maybe
speaking of Sentinel back in the trailer
for season nine when he ripped open the
bunker doors did you get an Iron Man
vibe I really did
Marvel and epic are big fans of one
another so this is likely an intended
nod to Tony Stark
hey we've moved on to movie references
so let's stick with them for a while
also in the trailer a passing blimp
overhead looks to be a reference to
another Tony this time Tony Montana from
Scarface and his drive to be the king of
the underworld in Scarface a blimp flies
overhead and gives Tony some great
advice the world is yours here in
fortnight's
same thing happens but the future is
ours
back in the battle past there is a piece
of music which is in reference to Blade
Runner I can't play the real music
because I'll be instantly claimed so
I'll tell you about Blade Runner instead
Blade Runner is a film set in the future
as humans are being replaced by Androids
spotting replicants is a career path and
killing them is Harrison Ford's job in
fact the character Demi in the battle
path looks to be part Android first her
arm has been removed replaced with
technology if you played Deus Ex you'll
recognize this version of the future as
everyday people augment their bodies
cyberpunk 2077 will release them play
that if that sounds like a cool premise
to you Demi's red arm could also be a
nod to Iron Man again or what about
snakes arm in Metal Gear Solid 5 there
is definite similarities every season we
get a new throwable a new chocobo this
season it was some sort of disc did you
know that that is taken from the sci-fi
movie Tron I reckon you already know
about the Tron bikes but the Tron discs
are a little less known but welcome to
the future oh let's quickly immortalize
some of these people who use code and
amaru when buying stuff in the shop
please think about using my code when
you grab next season's battle bus I'd
really appreciate it
but of course this is a two-way street
what do you want in return for using my
code let me know and I'll try and make
it happen no pressure
UVU but thanks once again if you've ever
supported me jiejie
[Music]
so the real John wick joined us in
season 9 what a breathtaking guy not
only did John show up but so did his
house it's really close to the original
his carries here too and in that
basement his loot - for being a
professional assassin even the place he
stays on business trips is here in
tilted the Continental
I love these touches these crossover
events they're so well done and there
was another one at the end of season 9
from stranger things from day one we all
noticed at the ice cream parlor in the
mega mall called scoops ahoy was taken
directly from the stranger things show
but it wasn't until the final week of
the season that the doors to the upside
down appeared pretty cool crossover Oh
music lovers did you pick up the chuck
berry inspired amount in the shop
if damn good isn't it we definitely need
to get 100 people doing this in molt in
a match are you up for doing that with
me right rock and roll in the comments
below and if we get 100 people we will
make that video before I get too
sidetracked let's go over to tilted and
the changed cityscape but did you notice
the banana stand well back in season 4 I
said this the chicken emote is taken
from Arrested Development a us situation
comedy one day we may see the banana
stamp - and here it is in Arrested
Development the banana stand has a
quarter of a million dollars hidden
inside have you found it in fortnight
yet around tilted pawns appeared in the
shape of signs and advertisements for
example the double plump restaurant is a
reference to double pump shotguns which
ruined the game in the early days the
turtle in hotel is a nod to the thing we
all do when under fire we all turtle
inside a structure later in the season
posters appears preparing us for the
live event these were designed to look
like World War 2 posters that we can do
each story is there to inspire the
female workforce and the Duck and Cover
images are remade which we're actually
there to prepare children for bombing
runs
be thankful we don't live in those times
speaking of the event which I'll played
full at the end of the video the final
battle the robot versus the monster you
probably made the link to the Power
Rangers right with the different parts
of the mech being different characters
well those who are a little bit older
will know that that mech is more akin to
Voltron ultimately the same as the Power
Rangers but he has a kick-ass sword like
this too by the way if you ever get into
an argument about Voltron versus the
Power Rangers throw in this tidbit
Voltron actually started out as Gold
Lion over in Japan but after middling
sales the footage was sold to an
American company who rieta dit and made
Voltron was that interesting it was
interesting to me the battle itself
takes cues from the mega fights in the
Pacific Rim movies honestly if you watch
them side by side you'll be surprised
how similar they are it's honestly it's
uncanny
before we finish there's a few little
things around the map which are worth
noticing did you see that Oldman
truckasaurus has been updated he
actually has a sword which must be a cue
to the final battle it was here the
whole time
Gigi who fought night development the
same thing can be said for the pool of
watering Tilted I originally thought
this looked like a spaceship
foreshadowing space travel in season 10
but look again it was shaped like a
sword the whole time hidden in plain
sight yet again damn it that's really
good design flesh factory returned in
season 9 as a nod to the og factory
which was crushed by the incoming
iceberg although season 2 go oh and have
you noticed that the house in West world
continues to have more chairs thrown in
it each week it's so strange what could
this mean
and one final piece of brilliance
remember the old retail role there was a
big fish that we could do this
[Applause]
yeah I loved it I really did well after
the volcano hit that town the big fish
was thought to be burnt to a crisp but
it was still here all along
looking southwest of the mega mall it
can be found still in one piece but it's
embedded in a house but the best thing
of all it still works
so there we have it what secrets and
easter eggs did I miss this season
please let me know in the comments below
and I'll put them in next season's video
I shall leave you with the final event
of the season the fight for the Power
Core and loot Lake the final battle if
you need a story breakdown I will link
one now but if not I'll see you next
season instead I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade thank you if you use : tomorrow
you if you don't know I'm kidding I'm
kidding I'm kidding don't unsubscribe
see ya
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]